Hey, what's going on? It's Belper and it's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
April 23rd, 2012. And uh,
I'm doing it on April 24th and
I apologize for being late.
Um, I had just been, I've been a little,
been a little busy, you know what I mean?
Isn't as that conti thing to say. You
know what I mean? I could've just said,
you know,
I apologize and I got to say I'm busy.
So what's I make you feel
bad. You probably didn't
feel bad. Did you assholes?
Anyway, so this is the podcast and this
week I have another special guest, um,
cheating again this week,
making it easy on myself, uh,
all the way from New Jersey. Ladies
and gentlemen, the legendary.
We brought you up a zillion times
on this podcast, Paul Versey.
It's good to be here, man. Paul,
Vinny, Michael, Anthony Versie,
what's going on from fucking New Jersey,
New York,
from New York and big time jets and
giants fan depending on who's winning.
You know,
it's funny about that.
People actually come up to me
now and they were like, oh yeah,
like some guys saw my name on a list to
do a show, and he goes, oh yeah. He goes,
oh dude, Bill [inaudible] was just
saying that guy, it's just listed like,
you know, like any team in New York who's
winning and stuff. And he goes, yeah,
he's right here. And I turn. He goes,
Oh, you're a poet. He goes, yeah man,
Bill Bonner was trashy today. And I
go, what did he say? He goes, well,
you're from Jersey. No, I'm
from New York and I'm a giants
fan. He goes, no. He said,
you're a jets fan too. I got, no,
he didn't. He goes, yeah, he did it.
And I know you had it. And that's the
exact reason why I did it. I did it.
So it would, people would just
be coming up to you. Yeah,
she do it on your podcast.
Just make up some shit about me
and then I'll have to deal with it.
I did that with Derosa,
the Rosa. Uh, when, when I,
when I moved out to La and he slid into
my spot on the opiod Anthony Program,
the running gag was that I was
upset that he stole my thunder.
That's the show that miss me.
So I started calling him the teen idol
sensation from the opiate Anthony Program
and people started calling him except
he loved it so that now we just call him
the sensation, which I think is one of
the great fucking nicknames out there.
Joey roses, roses is a great nickname.
Nia came up with that. That's a great one.
Joey roses called that.
That's what he should be called is
it's fucking old school. So that,
that makes me thrilled.
Thrilled that people are bothering you.
The Jersey thing is sticking,
man. You're getting me with dude.
You look like a guy from New Jersey.
I know. To be honest with you. Well,
this is to give people a background
here on, uh, on, on Paul, Michael,
Anthony Versie,
whatever,
whatever Italian middle name
you fucking is my nickname.
My middle name is Thomas Paul Thomas.
He is like, I can't tell you he's,
he's been going off on how fucking awful
New Jersey is like a typical New Yorker.
What he does is he goes through the
Lincoln tunnel and he drives to Newark
Airport. He sees Ikea and some of those
awful chemical things and then you,
you start thinking that Jersey is the
less chemical things like that is less
than the whole term. Pike is
less than, the air is horrible.
The traffic is terrible and
the people were stupid. Right.
Is Disgusting. And, and,
and, and, and, and, and the,
the, the, the people are stupid.
Right. I never said that.
You said that. Don said that people
are stupid. I said the crowds are low.
You're going to pull back on the park.
You're going to hold back. No, no, no.
The crowds are a little dumber in Jersey.
Damn.
Fucking say what you have to
say that they're a little dumb.
They're just more like animals,
like, you know what I mean?
The animals did just like, you
know, I got to tell you like,
do you get more of that in
general? I am not biased. Okay.
As a fucking outsider. There's a
part of you that I can tell you. Oh,
I definitely hate New York,
New Jersey too. Oh, all right.
Just as far as like their sports teams,
I hate them.
I wish misery on all you guys
cause you're a bunch of cunts. Um,
and the only reason I'm saying that is
because I've been behind enemy lines,
but anybody from Jersey or New York who
went to bu or came up in [inaudible] and
it's the same thing when you're
behind enemy lines, you, you hate,
you thought you hate the red
sox until you moved to Boston,
then you really fucking hate him.
And that's what happened to me.
I lived in New York during that whole
curse of the Bape thing and then we
fucking finally beat
you guys. And Alia, you,
you run in whole hide is fucking Pete.
Corey.
Ellie says y'all ran and hid. Oh No,
I'm happy for you. I'm happy for you.
See you later. Everybody fucking
ran out. Right? So, but I'm saying,
but I equally hate all of
that. So being unbiased. Dude,
I cannot tell the difference between New
Jersey and New Jersey crowd of fucking
upstate New York guy like you and
fucking long island out in governor's,
it's all the same. Oh, no,
no, no. I think the crowds,
I think the crowds can be both good.
But I think they're smarter in New York.
I do. I remember one time, uh,
Mike D's to finals on and Eagle.
He did a joke and it didn't
go, it something happened
in Jersey. He goes right,
right over the fucking bricks.
He was just confirming.
That's right over the bridge. I, yeah. No,
I'm not saying that they're not
more suburban. Absolutely. But Paul,
if you think that you're somehow smarter,
then those fucking Jackass
is in New Jersey. I've just,
from where I'm standing,
I don't see the difference. I
really dope. That's ridiculous.
You guys all do the same thing.
Oh,
whenever you eat and do a
sandwich and you like it,
you fucking drop it for half a second.
You look down the street like, oh,
taste the fucking bugging you,
bugging that thing.
It's all the same fucking guy to me.
Oh my God, I'm breaking you play.
You're gonna tell me
you don't go to Boston.
It's not a bunch of fucking freckled
face guys would clatter rinks. Oh my God,
that acts fucking socks. Stove. Oh my
God. It's horrific. Yeah, my friend.
I'm not defending it. I'm not. We're
angry. Fucking psychopaths. We are.
You got,
you have deep rooted hatred for New York
because you were hurt by the Yankees.
Okay.
Here's a problem with you.
You hate the Yankees more than we've had
great discussions about sports. Yeah,
I absolutely hate the Yankees come up.
I've seen a sport.
I've seen you go from a fun loving
sports conversation. I hate them too.
A Yank and all of a sudden you just get,
because you guys eat and he's just,
he's just buy your way out of
every fucking problem. Right.
But that's not my problem as a fan bill,
that's,
I'm not saying it is your problem.
I'm saying why I hate it.
Stop making it about you.
It's about my hatred of
the fucking Yankees and all
those stupid fucking songs.
If I can wake up and all the
losers in New York, walking around,
eating fucking eaten pizza,
slice of pizza next to the met,
and you're fucking sweatpants, you know,
we'll fucking piece of work in there.
They think they're a part of it.
That's what kills me.
The amount of people in New York live
like fucking animals. And I know too,
I lived there. I fucking lived
there. I was sleeping on a futon.
It fucking 34 pain,
1400 bucks a month in a fucking studio
apartment that they slammed a wall into
and fucking told me it was a one
bedroom until the night I went upstairs.
I met the girl upstairs, right? Yeah.
And I fucking went up to her apartment
and she had the exact same unit right
above me and it was a fucking studio
and she was paying way less than me, uh,
and a city that doesn't sleep.
I love New York.
You got to him in New York's great.
Oh, it's the Paris. It's the Paris of,
of the United States. Without a fucking
doubt. I think it is our best city,
but the amount of people who are in New
York and who just think that they're
winning just cause they're
there and they're not.
And if they would just move across the
fucking river into Jersey and not live
like a fucking animal,
they could just be as dumb.
They could still wear the sweatpants is
good pizza out there, but they don't.
They got a p like near all these things
that other people are making money on so
that they can feel like, you
know, come on dude, you walk to,
if you walked into one of those
Trump towers, they'd spit on you.
They throw you right out in the
street. That's hilarious. Nah Man.
Brainwasher after every fucking
Yankees game win or lose. But
you guys walk out. I see you walk out on
air. You're feeling good about yourself.
Yeah, I mean, listen, I'm
happy. I'm happy I lived there.
What do you want me to tell
you? No, no, no, absolutely.
I now am I saying no and I'm
saying it's awesome. I love it.
I just hate the fucking Yankees.
I don't even hit the rangers.
I and I love the rangers coach.
I actually really like the Rangers.
I like the Rangers. I like the
island islanders. I like the Knicks.
I like the mets.
And you liked the giants and I
actually like the giant like nice.
I love the giants. I love, I love uh,
how they, how their defense first.
I love, I love, I like the uniforms.
I love the old Helene went back to the
old Frank Gifford. The Yankees ruined you.
Yeah, that's the one thing that I
noticed. It wasn't the Yankees, it was,
it was how it was also reading the sports
page and just the fucking pot shots.
They be taken these,
cause I was reading the Dan Shauna's
sees of New York just taking these stupid
shots at a,
you know,
cause it just trying to sell papers
because they're fucking lazy and all they
gotta do is trashed the red sox.
Right.
Was that you said Dan Shaughnessy brings
baseball and everything no matter what
he's talking about. That's what I love
about that guy. That guy, that guy,
he has his hustle and he sticks with it.
If he was talking about the Bruins
last year and he's just everybody,
like everything was a red sox
references Milan, Lou Cheech,
like the Grady little of
the Boston Bruins. Yeah.
I was on the train with him once.
It was after. You guys want to,
I was just sitting at drunk. It was
funny. It was drunk. New Yorkers.
You guys won game. One of it was
I, it was all three or all four.
Mike Mussina lost the game. Oh, pause.
Oh four we lost. He lost the first three.
Let me just remind you,
we lost the first three and then
somehow you guys lost four in a row.
Biggest choke ever. Biggest joke
ever as far as like, you know,
four or five first ballot hall of Famers,
$215 million.
I have to take that responsibility.
That was the worst. I know you do.
That's like when you fuck up in a game
and then afterwards you talked to the
meeting going, I take full
responsibility. We know you fucked up.
Just sit there and listen to me. Say it.
Yeah. Cause you have to keep printing.
It was funny watching Dan,
Sean to see his face on a subway in New
York City with drunk Yankee fans who
just saw their team lose game,
one of a big playoff series.
And I was sitting there
next to somebody and go,
well the fuck this dude we're going to.
And he was just sitting there kind of
just like looking around with his eyes and
his fro he hair and he's got that,
you know that little boy Irish,
he's got to watch out now because
he's on ESPN now. He's not,
he wasn't as well known back then. So
yeah, he was down there covering it. His,
his whole angle was the
misery of red sox fans.
So when they finally won, like his hustle
was over, he didn't know what to do.
And I remember an o five, the red sox
were in first place and we started, uh,
we started to fade in
September is oh five, right?
And he wrote some article is the curse
back and it was like the curse of what
fucking 11 months ago because
you guys got a thing with, um,
you guys got to think which
fade in September last year.
End Up worst collabs ever.
How'd that work out? Well,
if we didn't win fucking
nine championships and all
sports, that would bug me.
Hey Man. You know what's great
though is that's all you got. You,
you used to use to go back to 1980
and you had to go back to you.
You're giving me shit about
September in 2011. Listen, Paul,
this is what I realized and this is what
the red sox failed to realize that in
life there are ups and downs.
No matter how much money you spend,
because I'll tell you, I abandoned
the Red Sox, uh, sometime in 2007.
I didn't even watch that world series
because at that point we became you guys.
We just trying to buy it every
fucking year. It's disgusting.
But Major League baseball, it's
fucking awful. You guys are Walmart.
We're fucking like cvs. Uh,
you know, you know what I mean?
It's just I don't give a fuck anymore.
I don't, I honestly don't give a shit.
And uh,
I remember I went to a Padres game,
beautiful stadium down there
and there was nobody there.
And I went there to the game with my
mother and she was looking nobody in the
stance. She goes, oh my God. She goes,
this is a sin, this beautiful ballpark.
It's not filled. And I was trying
to explain to her it is a sin.
I was trying to explain
to where they'll do,
we took the only fucking reason to go
to the game that whenever that first
baseman is, I don't watch baseball
anymore, but he was the guy,
he was there fucking cheater and we bought
them. Now there was no reason to go.
Is it that Gonzales guy? You got
it? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. No,
I don't watch baseball.
Baseball is,
I am way more interested
in my New York Knicks.
I'm way more interested in other sports
because I mean I can't watch, uh, uh,
well I, I, I'm the era cheater
can know. You know, it really is.
It did get rejected.
You then watch Cano Cano Cano was your
boyfriend knows my favorite baseball
player of all time for the Aussie guys
who never listened to this podcast.
Versie has a fucking man. No, I,
I just love how you hate that
cause you fucker so homophobic.
I love it man crush. So ridiculous. It
is ridiculous. And you know what happens?
Your eyes always get squinty and he'd
get upset and that's why I say it.
This is why I like Robinson can all cause.
Dude I fucking called it.
That's why they listen to this called
and it's a classic Paul Versey Call
Classic Paul Versey. He you call it
the blue shirt blue chip prospect.
He was and the Yankees System
update got a hunch on this kid.
You're telling me he sucks
all the way through fucking
baseball. He sucked. Right.
And that's why the Yankees brought
him back him up and they're like, oh,
you know who else Paul called this year?
Cam Newton, the Heisman trophy winner.
This guy. Yeah, but every
Heisman trophy winner. You're
the worst. The worst. No, no,
no. I have a call. You call everybody. You
call, you call blue chips and then, no,
no, no, I'm never going to give you, I'm
never going to give it to you cause I,
well I'm not accepted. They were like,
they were, they were, they were like,
oh they're going to trade him
to the twins. All my friends.
And now this guy's just to come in up
because you know he's just coming up
because we need a second base right now.
All these guys that you can't
bring in here as evidence,
they all disagree with you.
He's a hall of Famer. Well,
I never looked at the guy like
he was a bum. I never did.
I don't understand why you,
this is the worst thing.
Like Paul does that shit where he
starts a sentence three fucking times.
So anytime.
He'll call me up like he made me hate
this guy and I don't even watch baseball.
He calls me anytime he does anything
like a fucking eight year old still
collecting cards.
It'd be like bill he gave tonight.
Oh God,
you missed it.
So Robinson Cano Robinson couldn't
do Robinson could know came up
lace the double brings in Gita.
Oh then you always do that.
Oh that fucking joy in your voice and
it just drives me. I made you, Hey,
I made you hate it made me hate him.
I know, but I will tell you this.
You know it's funny. I was like, when we
first started arguing Yankees, I would go,
Bill, you're crazy. I would go, the
payroll doesn't mean Shit, you know,
it doesn't mean other
places where I've been,
all of a sudden we got like to
share and then we got like the,
they already had a rod at that point. It
was ridiculous. Then after awhile ago,
you know what I gotta look, this is what
this is. That's how I look at baseball.
You cannot buy a championship.
All right? But you can turn.
Making the playoffs into a
layup and this is the deal.
You can miss a layup like
the red sox last year.
Anybody can miss a layup and
like the brewers, you can,
you can hit a half court shot,
but genuinely fucking speaking,
if you look at the American league east,
it's been Yankees red sox every year to
the point I'm burned out. Like, dude,
I used to get so fucking amped up for
those games and part of it is because we
won a world series, but
I gotta be honest, Dude,
when you haven't played each other 50
times a fucking year and they're always in
first place,
always in second place.
It's like watching a comic who's on 10
the second they get on stage and they're
screaming like they're
doing their closing bit for,
for for the first 12 minutes sheet,
you're exhausted. You're like, all right,
I can't, I can't. I gotta listen
to the 50 minutes of this.
I can't listen to that anymore.
I actually think the baseball
season's just long and drawn out.
Like I could really give a shit until
August. September. I think it's a hunt.
I think it's too long. I, I'm bored to
tears. I think baseball, the older I get,
the more I think baseball
sucks. Oh really? Yeah. I
still think it's a great game.
I watched Kansas City of against the AC
of the day and it was like a rain delay
and there was nobody in the stance
and I loved it. I'm a grumpy old man.
I can only do something.
When we,
when we were at that Laker game and we
were watching that, I just said to myself,
this is fucking awesome. Basketball
is fast paced, you know, good passes.
The falseness show until the end,
until the end, until the end.
Well you don't like the bomp bomp
bomp bomp bomp bomp anytime, you know,
during the whole game
[inaudible] they do that,
you know that that's just to get the
crowd pumped up and stuff. But yeah.
But we kind of saw some loser fans.
Do you have that?
You have to have a height man.
The whole show's bomp Bomp d fans,
bom,
bom thief Fed stood back in the day.
You used to judge the fans by what they
chanted. You can still kind of do it.
Like the weight flyer fans chanted when
they went up three games to none against
the penguins. They just spontaneously
started chanting. You can't beat us.
It was fucking great. Now that says a lot
about your fans is like a personality.
There's a character to that. But like
you go to a fucking Laker game and it's,
they have like a DJ even have like a,
they have a fucking nightclub.
I sat up there for like a kings game,
the stupidest shit in between periods.
They start playing like music and
there's like chicks dance and it's the
stupidest fucking thing ever. Yeah.
Um, but like basketball, I like,
the only thing I don't
like is in the end there's,
I just don't like how it's this war.
And then in the end I watched them
take unguarded shots to win the game.
It's like anticlimatic in the
timeout, timeout TV. No, they got,
that was a good file. They had a file
to give. Then they stopped the clock.
And then the worst is when the other
team has already lost the game.
And just to be conscious.
They call timeout again. Yeah.
You just delaying the inevitable and uh,
you feel like a landlord trying to get
some piece of shit out of the apartment.
Yeah, I made sense. But they got
what? They got to hit the shots.
That's the one thing about it. You got
to hit the foul shots, you know? I know,
but it turns into golf ball. It's like
a guideline and up a putt now. Yeah.
You know what I mean? It gets drawn out.
It gets thrown up. But I'm such a sports,
I'm so nuts with sports. I
don't get how like, you know,
there some people like [inaudible]
quick, it's in and out. I'm like, wow,
I got to tell you hockey
starting to do that. Hockey,
this is the thing about hockey. You get
one time out of game. I think you do,
cause I've watched it for 30 years.
They never used them.
Every once in a while they'd
call a timeout and the
coach would just be sitting
there with a rolled up
program screaming at guys,
just BB would just take a time out because
he couldn't wait to the edit of the
game to tell the team how fucking
disappointed he was with the way they were
playing. And that was the time. Now
I'm finding at the end of the game,
they're starting to call
timeouts at the end of the game.
And it sucks because like I,
that's what I like about hockey.
I like how it it, it just
keeps moving. And people did,
they get involved in like
the scoring and everything.
And I totally understand that hockey is
a very difficult game if you didn't grow
up with it to get into.
It's a very difficult game to watch on TV,
but once you fucking understand it,
it's, it's the best. Get to that flyers.
Penguin series was the shit you want
to talk about fucking animals. Okay.
You know, I'm not a big hockey
guy. I love the three major sports.
Maybe it's because I grew up in New
York. I, you know, I'm not a hockey guy.
It never was my uncle too.
It's a fast game, Paul.
It takes a certain level intellect.
My uncle took me to a,
an islanders game years ago,
but this shit, this playoffs,
it's like fucking MMA on skates.
These guys are fucking barbaric.
That Shit,
that highlight game I saw against up,
it was a New York in Ottawa when the
guy just came up and it wasn't like,
you know the typical fight where
they wait, they look at each other,
but the officials know what's going to
go down. Gloves come off and they get,
it wasn't that this dude just came
up and basically you could tell,
you could watch as he skated, he mentally
just tapped out of the game and said,
it's fuck it's dom fighting this guy.
He came over,
he could start fucking
teen off on this guy.
Benches cleared and I just saw blood and
guys just looking to hurt somebody and
I've never seen that. It's,
it's, that's hilarious.
Kills hockey is because those are the
highlights. They show like, you know what?
What's his face?
Did their metal world peace in the game
we went to where he through the elbows
to where it's so stupid
that I love that name. No,
but the fact that people actually
call him that and let them,
it themselves like wow.
I mean Metta,
you gotta you gotta you
gotta go Cosell on that.
Like how Cosell would say I lean
and everyone was going Cassius clay,
he gotta gotta go metta world peace.
It's this,
he's such a nut job that
it's fucking beautiful.
You know what it takes me back to when I
first started watching the NBA and that
guy world B free was in the
league. He's a, I think,
I don't want to slander the guy,
but I,
I think he had some issues and
then he came around and uh,
and then he changed his name to world B
free. That's who's great. He went bald.
The way old school people went bald.
We didn't shave the sides, you know,
black guy,
he had the John Amos thing going on and
he played for the Cavaliers by
the time I was watching him.
I forget who we played for before that,
but he was a guy who,
who I may be confusing them with Maurice
Lucas. As far as like his background,
I can't remember if he had
the same recreational issues,
but like to the NBA in the late seventies
right before burden magic came in,
was this weird time when they,
the,
they basically they merged with the
Aba ratings were so fucking low.
They're the,
first of all they had a major drug
problem cause that's when coke came around
and they came up with the brilliant
thing saying that cocaine was no more
addictive than caffeine. It was kind
of a rich person drunk and yeah,
and everybody got like everyone, football,
Hollywood, Henderson, all these guys.
So the,
the,
there was a bunch of guys who had fucking
cocaine problems were in the league
and white people were still getting used
to the fact that black people own the
sport and that it wasn't coming back.
You know,
anytime soon it was fucking over when
all of a sudden Dr Jay brought the game
above the rim. Once it was above the rim,
it was all for all you can be with set,
set shot Johnny or a good fucking
pass or as far as a white guy,
which is something I think I talked about
in this podcast is how whenever we go
to an NBA game, we have that inside
joke. When the white guy screws up,
we just look at each other and we go,
fucking white guy.
Best best is when we went to Portland,
we went to Portland and the guy did it
and in unison at the same time. Yeah.
You said, what did he do? He missed
it. He was like a wide open layup.
It was just something that was
absolutely so horrible and just such bad.
He looked horrible doing it. Look
terrible doing it. And you said,
you mentioned this once before,
but we looked at each other and it was
exactly until we just go fucking white
guy, white guy, get him
off, get him out of that.
Give him a clipboard and some fucking
long select set of a suit or something.
He looked bad.
It was something easy.
It was something that should
have been terrible. We're off.
We don't even look good. Even the good
guys don't look as does dark new whiskey.
Does he look good now? We were
talking about if we did a Larry Bird,
did he look good when he did the things
he did? He did. It just went in one. No,
but but Dirks like there are certain
guys would unacceptable faces.
That's why I was thinking about the
website on the unacceptable faces and
sports.com or worst faces in sports.com
which we were talking about yours.
Who are the ones that you hate the most?
Oh Scott Brochure.
Sunny Yankee third basically bank is is
one of the worst hate on the red sox.
We just train them to the Phillies. Oh my
God. There was nothing worse in sports.
Nothing.
Then that fake like hardcore
intense look in that.
Jonathan [inaudible].
I love it yet to say safe.
Fake now cause you knew he
was striking out your player.
He made his lips kind of come together
and he looked in like you, yeah,
his lips came together and you had the
thing and his eyes came down and he just
stared and then he did the thing and
it was just almost like, okay. The big,
the big dramatic. Ah, it
was the absolute worst.
Podres faces a little unacceptable,
but he actually tries hard.
So I liked that guy. But what are you
thinking about Reggie Miller's tries hard.
The MVP,
there's some conos never done is kind of
easy to be the MVP when you're fucking
nestled in there between Jeter
and to Sharon, a rod. Oh Gee.
You're seeing a lot of pitches
to Robinson. Ken Robinson,
Robinson Cano. Ah, single
though. Do you think we were talking
today about a Reggie Miller's faces?
Reggie Miller had an unacceptable
face. No, mine would be to share,
to share has got a deaf to share. I
don't know what it is. And I'm like,
when he's in an interview, he looks
intelligent. When he's out in the field,
he looks intelligent. The second that
bat goes above his head, I don't know.
He looks, he looks like some extra on
fucking the Andy Griffith show. He looks,
he looks like he's having a hard time
thinking he looks like he's going to puke.
Zero Iq is what he looks like.
I don't know if he shuts his brain down
and just be the balls. See the ball,
be the ball.
I don't know what he's doing,
but he just looks like [inaudible]
got an unacceptable facing sports.
He would be on the list.
I don't know how high he would be,
but he's got an unacceptable face.
Who did you say was worse than brochures?
She said somebody who all you said
somebody who is worse than brochures. Oh,
going through going through the years as
far as awful faces are Danny Ainge and
spices. Oh, Pau Gasol. Oh, pat.
Paul was saw when when they call a foul
on Pau Gasol off. That's the worst thing.
Oh,
he's got an unacceptable face to nothing.
We would think that somebody just said,
yeah, listen, Pau Pau, your career's over.
You're not making any more money.
That's the face he makes. Like, whoo.
Nothing's worse than an athlete
that that is. Good and just ugly.
And every time he see me like Ah,
Larry Bird wasn't a good looking man.
Bill notice you hate all Boston guys.
Oh No,
I'm just saying because they just took
a lot of their faces are unacceptable.
I never found any of the
next phases unacceptable.
I love their look of defeat every
time we played them in any major game.
Do they ever going to win a championship?
So this is one thing I've
got to give you shit about.
You got to admit at this
point you say the very least.
New York definitely has a problem with
crowning people king and giving them
ridiculous nicknames before they've done.
They have like fiber like Lynn Sanity.
You can add that to sand shies man.
Genius Godzilla. Godzilla
was great though. I liked,
I liked the name Godzilla
but I fit man Godzilla,
Godzilla cause he dominated
the Japanese league,
which at this point I'm starting
to think I could play over there.
The fact that Valentine
won the world series.
All those Japanese players who've come
over there and all of them had best,
they're fundamentally sound except for
each row and they all come over here like,
like dice k, the Gyro ball.
Uh, what's his face? Uh,
Matsui coming over Godzilla. He's going
to hit 800 home runs. You know what dude?
They don't know.
Okay.
They trying to act to know you
go to the Dominican Republican,
Republican Republican, the Dominican
Republic. That's where you go.
That's where it starts. That's
where, yeah, yeah, exactly. And,
and you called him. It's amazing. I
can't believe that that in Cam Newton,
dude, I don't know how you figured
that one out, but the Cam Newton thing,
all I was saying was that, would you
disagree with that guy with the, the,
the game show host hair on ESPN?
A lot of,
a lot of Heisman trophy winner is coming
to the NFL and their bus and you know
that they're fucking bust. And
everybody, I do, I do know that part.
But I also know that you, you, you first
of all, every year you call 20 things.
You like the guy who,
who you bet,
you bet show place to when you
fucking bet everything you go,
everything's straight across the board.
And then you at some point
you're gonna have a winner.
No, no, no, no, no, no. See,
this is what this is.
Paul goes,
I'm standing up right now because
you're really fucking bugging me.
You're the one, you were with all those
clowns on ESPN telling me that fucking,
that fucking, uh, that Peyton
manning was better than Tom Brady.
When would Peyton heads on the bureau
rings and fucking Brady has toes.
I was definitely wrong about it.
Okay. Talk to me out of that.
But I'm admittedly way
too harsh on that guy.
But the unbelievable level of fucking
disrespect. Tom Brady got the,
he had three fucking rings and they were
still going, but dude, I got to toilet.
You know, I've got to tell you if I
got it started, fucking guy, but blah,
blah blah.
And all these stupid cold fans this year
who said the cults go and fucking Oh
and 14 is a testament as to
how good Peyton manning is.
It's it dude. It's partly that
and it's partly how awful you are.
Fucking franchise was how zero you had
zero depth at the quarterback position
because the guy had never missed a start
and he lulls you into this false sense
of security where you went from fucking
Peyton manning to some guy you got off a
car. Well that's fine. Without him they
were nothing and you can't have that.
That's,
and they were also already on their way
out and they weren't going to win 13
games this year with him. They weren't.
They were all there on the way down.
Double digit wins. I think they'd
have with him this year I think to,
I think they get to the play 10 and six
and he gets to play tennis six maybe 11
and five but they weren't
going to be 13 and three do.
They couldn't even beat
the fucking jets last year.
They had the game won and they still
blew it. That's another thing too.
Too many first round losses with
that guy. But I have a feeling, um,
I don't think he's got enough
guys out there, but I mean,
look, I have admittedly,
did you know what? This is the real
thing of my hatred of Peyton Manning,
my hatred of pate manning stemmed out
of the complete disrespect of Tom Brady
and then I blamed it on Peyton
manning is if he said it,
I mean the guys obviously first
ballot fucking hall of Famer,
but I got to tell you,
dude,
he's got too many first round playoff
losses against too many mediocre fucking
teams. I've talked about this
many times. Tom, terrific.
And he doesn't deserve to hold anything
else that Tom Terrific is the fucking,
I think I've made it. We've gotten
too many arguments. I think he,
if he gets one more,
it solidifies it.
I think that that man has
played to position as good,
if not better than anybody else ever.
And pate manage or is true. Can't throw,
pick six and a Superbowl.
Can't do it through a pick six and a
Superbowl to lose it, to lose. That's bad.
That's bad, but I guarantee you this,
I'll guarantee you this though, if,
if he wins the second one,
if he wins another one with the Broncos,
you'll never hear Tom Brady's name. It'll
all be about, it'll all be about him.
He just, he has that thing
because you know what to think.
He had the advantage of when he went
outside and his backyard to play catch.
He was playing catch with the fucking
professional quarterback. So the guy,
the guy's like, he's been around,
he's fucking flawless. Oh yeah.
And he's flawless. He is the Anti Tim
Tebow. He might be one of the best people.
I'll tell you his brother, his
brother, if you could insert Tim Tebow,
his heart into that giant tin man,
Frankenstein,
you would have the ultimate quarterback.
I think Eli Manning,
I think his brother Eli Manning has a
lot more balls and his, his, uh, his,
you got balls. They don't get mad at
debt. No. Eli's a fucking winner, dude.
He's got ice in his veins.
He's, uh, he taught absolutely.
You don't need to tell me that.
He fucking stuck me in the heart twice.
He's another face guy though. He's another
guy. You look at his face and it's,
it's, it's just, you know,
you don't think he's got the heart that
he's got when you look at his face. Yeah.
Both of them. I don't know what it is
about their faces. They uh, you know,
that old joke, he doesn't quite look
done yet. Put them back in the oven.
They both have that. They have, they have
cookie dough faces. Yeah. But I think,
I think Peyton is a, I think Peyton is
definitely pay this pay. This is a man.
Eli's the fucking bag. I like, I just
get people going on the podcast, but uh,
I, I obviously don't fucking disrespect
those guys and I obviously know that the
Broncos are going to be a way better
team and I respect the fact that,
that this is what actually made
me like Peyton manning now.
I actually kind of switched because he
could have gone with the 40 niners and,
and, and that when he did and he said, I
don't want to, I don't want to be like,
like thinking that I just piled on.
So right then that that's
it because Clemens, shit,
when I watched Clemons, when those
two rings, when he jumped in Limo,
when you guys fucking,
we're already winning championships and
he slid his fat roided ass through the
sunroof.
Anal is worse than that.
He said before that he would
never want to play in New York.
Like that's another thing about that guy.
I think that that guy is just a bad human
being. I'd really don't like that guy.
There's nothing likable about him
and you know what the fighting is.
Every time I beat the shit
out of both of us, every time.
Every time I saw Roger corn these days
run into one of these people I'm talking
about. I mean fucking trouble. Every
time I saw Roger Clemens pitch live fee,
he got shelter every time.
Just shit the bed.
Every time I saw him and he goes, I don't
like them. Yeah, you could see that.
That really think coming though.
Cause he was fucking gigantic.
And I swear to God,
living in New York City,
I think like six times a year they would
do some sort of insider story about his,
his, his workout in everybody
was walking around. Cool, dude,
you see this guy's workout? It's like,
that's exactly what they want you to say.
So anyways, let's get, let's get back to
fucking metal world peace here through.
There's not one woman still listening
to this podcast. We've talked sports.
Stop for a half. I mean, done a fucking
commercial yet. Here. Paul, let me,
let me do a commercial. When we come
back a little metal world peace.
You'll listen to the fan,
uh,
with the fucking password.
I got to type in here. Paul,
how'd you like riding around in my truck?
I was at. That's awesome by the way.
And even, yeah, mentioned that
you crashing out here. Uh,
you like that three in the tree.
How fucking bad ass is that?
That's a bad ass truck.
That truck looks like you have a rightful
in it and you're just about to go do
something really, really bad.
That's what I like about it.
It looks like I know how to fight.
That's somebody told him. I said, dude,
I look at their trucks like the kind of
truck you get into after you just beat
up everybody in the bar now. You said the
funniest shit. You Go. I go, that truck,
it looks like a bad motherfucker is in
it and you just go yet till I get out
dude.
The difference of the looks that I get
between driving my truck and driving the
Prius is fucking hilarious. Oh yeah. Dude.
Fucking eight year old. Stare me
down when I get out of my, no,
the front girl of your
truck looks like you.
Just something like bad happened in your
past. All right. Wait a second here.
Where the fuck is a,
what the fuck is the, uh,
all the God damn advertising. See
this. This is what happens, Paul.
This is when it slows down is when it
slows down. Paul, what do you got to hype?
Why don't we, why don't we, why don't
we try and do something with you here?
What do you got to High Paul? Uh,
where can people see you next?
I've got a couple of shots in Jersey.
I know that going out and going
grocery shopping, right? No,
I'm actually going to be at the,
um, I got a big show coming up.
You got a big show. Where you
going to be? I'm going to be in.
You've got a really big shoe in
the back of this Deli in Jersey.
It's a guy's giving me 10 minutes now.
Um,
what a fuck is all the game fly stuff?
I'm the worst.
Oh go ahead. Puff up. You
can not do what you gotta do.
No, I can't park cause in
the podcast stops. All right.
I already got this shit
memorized. Hey everybody, do
you like playing video games?
Sure. We all do. Check this up. All
your big video game guy right now.
You're not a big video game now and
I still roll with it. Oh okay. Yeah,
no but holy shit,
I gotta start over.
I got to start over cause my ad guy
cuts these things up. No, no, no.
I can't say cut during and my kids say
any that just shut up when we start over
again. All right. Hey, who
likes playing video games? Sure.
We all do. Paul Versey. Do
you like playing video game?
Love them. You love them?
Absolutely. No. If you had to
choose between that and a loved one,
you're going to video games,
right all day. Absolutely.
All Day. Absolutely. Dude,
you called it. Um, if you're in a video
games game, fly.com is the place to be.
If you go there as a friend of mine,
game fly.com/bill,
click on the microphone in the corner.
You're going to get a 15 day free trial.
Wow. 8,000 gains. Paul, that's
8,000 games to choose from.
What do you need a girlfriend? Now, why
do you need to? Why do you need a wife?
Why did you even need to
be a parent at that point?
Just lock yourself in the room.
You get 15 days.
That means you can play those games,
Paul, for two weeks and a day.
I know you from Jersey, so you don't
understand that. But two weeks in a day,
15 straight days,
you can play 8,000 games and at the
end if you want to walk you walk,
just like de Niro and heat. Okay.
30 seconds or less. That's right.
You can't do any better than that. All
right, game fly.com I recommend it.
You should recommend it and some day your
mom will too. There we go. All right,
back to the podcast. Um,
Metta world peace dude.
You know what's funny about that guy?
Like he had no intentions of elbowing
that guy in the head while he was just so
in the moment. But this is the
thing. He's like that, you know,
that kid that wasn't special needs but
almost was and he had like that Olympic
weightlifter kind of strength. That's
fucking world peace. That's how he is.
And those kids, whenever they
got angry or excited, he's,
somebody got hurt. Somebody got hurt or
something got ripped out of the wall.
Fucking nuts. There's no you don't.
That's what happened with them. He,
he went in and he, he scored,
he started thumping his chest.
Somebody can't hear him and he
just fucking throw an elbow.
We're talking about a man who jumped in
the stands and grabbed a civilian by the
neck and started teeing off on him. I'll
give you this. He grabbed the wrong guy,
but he was fucking right. Now we're
in a perfect world. He's right.
That's like built in audiences where,
where in this fucking world
can you throw a drink in a,
in the face of a guy
who is twice the size,
you will not get the living
shit kicked out of you.
I'll tell you where that a fucking
NBA basketball game where there's no
protection. They don't have that helmet.
The helmet. No. You're a fucking hat on.
This guy throws a drink in his face. That
guy, you just see the guy through it.
How many, how many, how many,
how many Edward Jokes do you think that
guy told and laughed about in his life
and they were in Indiana.
Gimme a break.
He probably had his fucking Klan
Hood underneath the seat. Fuck him.
He should've got the shit kicked out of
him and I feel bad for the web designer
that actually got
grabbed by the throat and
that guy, that kid had never
been in a fight in his life.
He didn't even know enough to run.
He didn't even know enough
to run all the look of fear.
He didn't even know what happened.
He just had horrified fear in his eyes
and then Ron Artest just because his feet
were moving, but he wasn't going anywhere
and then he was trying to explain what,
I'm trying to explain. The situation
was going to like this. If you're on,
if you're at a comedy club here on stage
and somebody throws something at you,
you're not going to do. As a matter of
fact, somebody threw something at you,
right? I know somebody,
I know somebody else.
I think somebody said they were flicking
stuff. I saw this woman, she goes really?
And she kind of just called the crowd
an animal, but as a professional,
you can't fall out there right now. If
you were doing a bit and for some reason,
oh, well let me get no, because
this was a different cause.
It was a bullshit call and that's
why he laid down on the table.
So let's just say you're, you're playing
some fucking hell Gig. All right.
The crowd socks. The microphone's
not working. So you like,
you gotta give me a fucking, I can't
even, I can't even get the show going.
I can't even speak into this microphone.
This is my light saber.
It's not even working.
And then you just make a joke and
you lay down until you get the,
you get the proper microphone
and while you're laying there,
some drunk dude takes a full
drink and throws it in your face.
You're telling me you're not going into
the crowd. He'll be tough. It'd be tough.
You know, I, I, yeah, it would be really,
I mean, that's got to do that then.
That's what I hated about
that whole thing with like,
well not excusing the fair behavior,
but as a professional basketball player,
you wrote the blue, blue, blue, blue. Now
you don't, you don't, you have a fucking,
you have a responsibility for your
own safety in the world. Okay.
And part of that responsibilities that
you don't walk around throwing drinks and
faces of people that you cannot beat
the shit out of her. Right? Right. Yeah.
So you do that and then somebody else
gets their fucking ass kicked because of
it.
I mean like I was a coward who's a fucking
coward or when he ran in the stands
or that was like unbelievable. He should
play. She played for the penguins.
Oh, I just like fucking with the
penguins. I was so happy that they,
I had this weird thing where I like
most of the people on the team,
but then they always,
they was just have a couple of those,
those fucking guys going for the
knees. I just don't like him. I can't.
Then they an end,
they always get like upset like penguin
fans when paying her fans talk about
other teams being dirty.
You know what that's like?
That's like that chick with the big tits
who goes to a party and has her tits
hanging out and it says like, you
know, what are you looking at? Right.
That's what penguins fans are to me.
I think.
I think they're all dirty like that Greg
Williams thing. You heard that right?
The Greg Williams, you had the Greg
waves on the saints, like the, the,
the what he was saying to them. Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. And when he was like,
kill the head,
kill frankly wars head.
That's where it's crossed the line.
When he said I wanted his head fucking
sideways. That's where cross line.
What I hated about how all
the players were going like,
I mean that just sounded like standard
locker room talk until they named guys.
It's like, no, no, no. He said,
obviously he said rip his AC. No,
but I'm talking about don't love it.
I'm in me.
He loves to put the point I'm making the
point of making was every player kept
saying, I've heard that stuff
in locker rooms my entire life.
But the part where he made it
like personally named guys,
that's where it went too far and it was
driving me nuts. It's like, yeah, dude,
that's what we're freaking out about. I
opt dude, when I was in little league,
the fucking coach is sitting there going
like, we've got to kick their fucking,
you know, the, a bunch of posters,
football update. It's always say that.
But when you literally go like the
shortstop, I don't like his face.
I want his fucking nose bond. Yeah,
right. I already got an ACL problem.
Why don't you go out there
and deliberately blow
out as ACL when you start
literally naming it, that's where it
crossed the fucking line. That's my thing.
It seems straight across the board that
none of the players had a problem with
it.
So now I don't feel bad that they have
the concussion problems that they have at
the end. Because if you actually, if
you participate in that, then you know,
but then that's kind of like
the chicken and the egg.
It's like if you don't do that, then
you're not on the team. Um, but I,
I actually agreed with everything
that they've penalties that they got.
And I think that this happens all
over. This happens all over, you know,
I don't think guys like Tony Dungy do it.
I don't think certain guys do it.
But I think, I think, you know, they'll
say go fucking get like, you know,
I think it's been once, listen
my deal, like go kill him,
rip his head off half his
head gone the other way.
But when you specifically name a player
and you say what their injury is and all
the plays, it's like we are, we
already know what their injuries are,
so we're definitely going
to try to exploit that dude.
You know what all of that is Paul.
That is,
it all has to do with millions
of dollars being at stake,
which brings in the horse and there's a
level pussy and it's all there and then
it's like,
dude,
you're getting to the top of the mountain
and it just becomes by hook or by
Crook and they're just going
to do that type of shit.
It's just really shit that as fans,
you didn't want to see,
he didn't want to hear.
ButW and now they make an example out of
that guy because everybody's livelihood,
including ESPNs is on the line that if
there's too much of that negative shit,
people aren't gonna Watch
it because, uh, that's,
that's the only guy in sports I don't
like is I don't like the guy who
deliberately goes up who
can't beat the other team.
So he deliberately goes out and tries to
injure a fucking player because I feel
like that requires no skill whatsoever
on any given play. You know,
people are watching the guy with the ball.
I know.
Keep your head on a
swivel is what's his face.
But at that time he said
that 80 fucking times.
Warren Sapp keep your head on a swivel.
I understand you're supposed
to be looking around.
Isn't it amazing how fucking out of
shape he was yet still was fat fast.
How fast? What did that Guy Ben,
if he dropped 40 pounds, dude,
he had that line on the side.
You know,
when he got that love handle that just
puts a divot his whole fucking career.
It looks fucking eight months pregnant
his whole career and he fucking could run.
And which was fast as hell
was fascinating. Anyway, is
it? Here's a good one. Worst,
worst sports bodies yet.
For some reason,
Phil Mickelson just pops to mind
first. Okay, I'll get one. Paul Pierce.
Paul Paul Pierce's arms. Yeah.
Are Unacceptable. Unacceptable.
You're okay.
You're an athlete and you're a black guy.
You should be fucking chiseled.
I'd be ripped.
I think he doesn't even have white guy
arms. He has like middle-aged accountant.
He, how does he do his two year
old? He's got 60 year old arms.
I think Peyton Manning's body's weird.
He's still got that little pot belly
belly the way he walks and he kinda, he,
he uh, he has a pot belly. You
see pate manning without his past.
He's got that gut. Yeah, he's got
sitting on a tractor body. Um,
Phil Mickelson definitely film Mcgee.
He's been better than lately. He's sweet.
He's just, he was off to coffers. I told
you that golf is not a fucking sport.
It's a skill.
It's a skill to the amount of guys I
know that suck at real sports like this.
Somebody trying to prevent you from
scoring and you have to like be able to
throw and catch or whatever, skate to
stick handle. They absolutely suck.
But then you put them on a golf course
and they can hit it straight because it's
like just this, this mechanics,
just a mechanical thing. Yeah. Yeah.
And it's all like, dude, it's you against
yourself. It's not, it's not dude. It's,
it's like, it's like pool,
but pool. You're also playing
some Adena on a bold goal.
He Golf, bowling, Golf.
You're also playing something.
They are bowling, bowling,
pool, golf. They're there. They're
tier two sports. I would say.
Although pool is cool as hell.
What do you think about NASCAR?
You never see a fat fuck driving
a car around 200 mile. Once again.
Once again though. Uh, yeah, we
gotta be in shape for that. Uh,
unless you can drive like a van.
There's not one fat NASCAR
driver. Really? Yeah,
but that just means they're in shape.
You know what I mean?
I look at everybody in China,
they're all,
everybody in China is fucking in
ridiculously good shape compared to this
country. That doesn't mean they
can all catch a ball. Right.
You just say somebody is in shape. You
know they're written well, but no, but,
but I, I once again, you think it's,
I have a friend of mine, same thing,
can't catch, can't throw, throw it like
a fucking girl. Anything with wheels,
forget about it. The guy becomes, he's,
he's one with it drives like a maniac.
He had a BMW five series and he
took me out on the highway, dude.
And I swear to God,
I almost fucking threw up.
It was like I was in an f 16 I had my
foot up on the dashboard going through.
Don't dude, I got it. I got it.
And he's just sitting there laughing
at me and then you get them out on the
court, but you throw a ball at him.
I swear to God, it's like a toddler.
Like those guys that go fast like that.
Man. That's so funny that you were going,
dude,
dude.
One time I was in college and we were
driving and me and my friend was rain in
my friends trying to show off and me
and my other friend didn't want to look
like, you know, we don't
like pussies. Right.
But we got some genuinely scared and like,
I don't know,
and to do it was just gone. And the
rain's coming down. I'll be my friend.
We're doing work that we go
to do. It's not worth it.
Not worth slow down. So yeah,
trying to calm. Yeah. Tried to
become like, no dude, listen to,
I think there's a cop, there's a cop
up there, but those guys that get that,
those are like those motorcycle guys
that need that speed. They fucking that.
That's scary shit too. That's one of
those, yeah, you're going so fast.
You're going to be like, well,
I'm going to work sedans. Bill,
you're going to wake up at injected
from the car if you're lucky.
If you're lucky, you're going to fucking
wake up. It's brutal. Fucking garbage.
Just joke
first.
He's got me addicted to Florentines
podcast and now verse, he does like,
he does a pretty good
Florentine Florentine is the
funniest motherfucker and I'm
listening to just warrantying complain
about anything. Oh my God. Oh,
buys care robot. You're fucking
kidding me. Garbage fucking show.
Like at Fox News robot. Fucking you. That
right robot. The way it goes like up.
All right. Like drags the word
out at half time. So again,
that's really good man.
He's fucking funny man. Let's get it
to that guy. Complained rarely, rarely.
Like we never seen a beautiful
woman before bud light commercial.
It's fucking ridiculous. Um,
all right. Uh, we got here.
This is a, okay. Sunglasses.
There's some really some weird ones
this week. People like this guy says,
hey bill, I need, I need to Mike,
my listeners sent in like questions and
shit and I read it just to let you know.
Billion. I need to ask you
a very important question.
My wife makes fun of my
choice of sunglasses.
She's thinks they're not hip enough.
Um,
I told her I was wearing brown tinted
sunburst aviators since college,
before the whole aviator hype.
Is there eight or hype?
I don't even remember top.
Yeah. So say back then,
those people who in 1980 [inaudible] yeah.
Who wanted to be like Tom Cruise.
You know, my neighbor when I was growing
up, any movie that Tom Cruise was in,
he got into that, like whatever
it was like a top gun. He
joined like the fucking,
uh, no, no. He joined like the, the,
the, the, the air force reserves,
the alligator arms. He joined that
and then, um, days of thunder,
he started racing cars. No cocktail.
He became like a bartender.
His Rich Dad got him out of the
fucking, uh, reserves. Yeah,
he started getting into that.
And what else did he do?
There was like three things.
So it kind of became this running joke,
like whatever,
fuck a Tom cruise movie was coming out
and then eventually he moved out to la
finally. Well, why don't we just
be a fucking actor, you know,
so I don't want to actually
join the fucking air force.
That's a don't know what ever happened
to him. So anyway, aviator glasses,
which were, yeah, the Tom
Cruise fan slash date rapist.
Remember that fucking kid
I was talking about him.
You remember that kid who he had the
rough sex with a girl in them in central
park and she died. No, you're too
young for that yet. This guy. Yeah.
This fucking psycho. No, he killed
her. He tried to, he tried to,
he tried to say that they,
that she wanted rough sex.
It was consensual and I
don't know what it, it, it,
he accidentally killed her or whatever.
I mean,
the whole of the meeting's going
to, we're killing it. Yeah.
Jesus Christ always kill it.
Crushed it. Fucking
crushed it. Um, so, oh,
anyway, still, that's fucking
brutal. So anyway, but this guy,
you know what actually made me mad when
he got out of prison, not only that, that,
that he got out of on two loves
and maybe men, first of all,
the guy got out of prison, but, uh,
the idiots on the news going off on the
guy was saying, because when he got out,
he wasn't on parole because he did all
his time because he didn't get time off
for good behavior because they were just
like, you know, he had fights in prison,
he was selling drugs and blah, blah,
blah. It's like, yeah, the, all the,
all that that says in there
as he didn't get raped,
he did what he had to
do in there to survive.
So on some level yet you have
to respect that because that's,
that's the big fear is a guy who did he
raped a girl or it was just rough sex.
I don't know what he did. I don't know.
What has such a big difference though?
Well, I don't know if he
went like Ron our tests,
like it was going good and he was
excited and then he fucking elbow.
Why are we joking about this?
Fucking started pounding his chest and
then they didn't show the replay because
it was a home game.
Um,
no, he, he fucking, I dunno. How long did
he, do they let him out of jail? Yeah,
he did like all 15 or 16 years because
they couldn't get him on murder because
he said it was like, I know like
on, on rape trials, like they, what
they always do,
like the,
the hardest thing to get them on
is when they say it was consensual,
so then all DNA is out the fucking
window. Then you have to like, it's,
it's, it's, it's the worst fucking thing.
If somebody does that to a woman that
they should be, honestly, they should,
they should just,
they should have like a flame thrower
and they should just have it pointed at
the defendant and Jerry,
would you like to read the
verdict on the count of a rape?
We find him guilty in the first degree.
It just just light them on fire
right in front of the family. Yeah,
right in front of it. Right in front of
the family. That's how I would run it.
Just same, same thing with
child molesters. Star,
that's the word I'm less is that's it.
Sham listed.
I would actually have them get chased
by rabid dogs first and then to descend
Dusky guy and it fucking,
the Sandusky guy should get fucking
drawn and quartered in the courtroom.
Just put his fucking body parts.
He should be underneath an oil tanker and
then they should drive it to fucking r
is that you got to drive a boat,
drive it to like fucking a man
that's walking this earth. These,
if that's what I would do with that guy,
what I would do with that guy. Well,
I would go into shark infested waters and
I would give him a bunch of paper cuts
and add time to the front of a boat.
Oh my God. I never heard of like that.
Well that's, that's a good one, man. Well,
you gotta understand. Wait, when you
do something like that to somebody,
you didn't just [inaudible],
you ended that kid's life and then you
affected generations of people because
who they're going to marry, how they're
going to treat the person they marry,
how they're going to treat their kids,
and then the treatment of the kids,
how they're going to act in
society, society. It just,
it creates, it's like that,
that little Confucius thing,
when you drop the pebble in the still
pond and the ripples just go like that.
And he got a little poetic on
you. It's like that. No, see,
that's why I say time to the
front of a boat, paper cuts,
shark infested waters and that's it.
And you know what's fun and this
is the thing about it. That's fine.
It'd be awesome. Um, and
it still wants stop him.
It's the one stop it from happening, but
you should just start weeding them out.
That's like, that's a sickness
man from young. It's fucking
crazy, man. Yeah, it's,
it, uh, that's just, uh, uh, and it
ruins the lives of everybody for, but,
but the kid forever. Yeah, it's over. Why
you saying what? I just said Paul. Oh,
did you set it up so you won't even
listen to the typical comedian? No,
we're thinking about what
you were going to say.
That's literally exactly what I just said.
No,
I was thinking about the use anymore.
I was thinking about him actually like
hitting the thing like a boat. Oh,
that's right. You got, you got that.
You got that weird fucking shit where
you every once in a while you just take
about doing crazy stuff, right.
I was getting nervous about it.
Mitton this type of stuff.
Like someday if you're like on trial,
like you know I'm going to get put in
contempt of court because that's still
never rat you out.
But it'd be like we talking about,
you guys talked about this on the
podcast but it kept me, it was a joke.
What's the less fucked up
thought you had? Um, well it's,
it's tough man, because my son
was born, I would think about,
I loved him so much and
when I would hold them,
all you think about was what if I, what
if I hurt? I have the power to hurt them,
but you love him so much
and it freaked me out.
And now my daughter's coming Monday, you
know, and, and I'm just kind of like,
I just, all you want to do is block it
out. And the more you try to block it out,
bad things happen. But no, I've, you know,
I'll sit down with somebody and talk to
me. The more he tried to block it out,
like bad things happen,
the more, the more,
the more you think the fucked
up does not say, man, I'm,
I don't want to think about that
cause it's crazy and fucked up.
What happens is it gets,
it just magnifies them to multiply in your
head and your head and it keeps going.
So what do you like stoically walking
with your kid towards your wife and just
handed off to her? No, no, no.
I just keep telling myself that you
wouldn't ever do it, but it's fucked up.
Like it's painful. But I've been dealing
with it for, so it's more like a fear.
You have like a fear like, oh my God,
what if I did this? It's not like a,
obviously an urge. No,
no, it's actually, it's a,
it's an urge that you won't act on it,
but you're not going to do it, you know?
But it's a fear and urge and it's first
he has inexplicably one of the smartest
kids I've ever seen a kid is,
is, is ridiculously smart.
And when I hang out with you,
Paul,
I just think that you must've married
one of the smartest women on the planet
because that kid is a genius.
I've been sitting with somebody and really
thinking about if I just would take a
vase and fucking smash it over their face.
And,
and the funny thing is you'll just,
sometimes you just have to like smile
and laugh and you can never tell the
person what you're thinking. But it's
OCD. It's what it is. You know what?
I actually woke up thinking today
and I was just laughing my ass off.
I was thinking about what if he just,
you videotaped a game called shut your
God damn mouth and you're the thing was
it just
you and a friend walk around and you just
randomly scream that it strangers who
are having a conversation and the first
guy that gets somebody mad enough to hit
them,
you can't hit him back.
The first guy to get some mad
enough to hit them wins, whatever.
And I was just picturing all the
different scenarios and just the amount of
people who don't fight in the amount
of people who have too much to lose.
The amount of people who would be would
be like startled and then you get like
the whole like race thing going on where
like as a white guy you think if I ran
up to a black guy did that,
this automatically is going
to beat the shit out of me.
But like this is something about when
you do that to somebody black as a white
person,
they think like know he knows I'm going
to kick the shit out of him and he's got
to be crazy. And then I think
people just think that in general.
Cause every one time, long time ago, I
was on a subway, I was on a subway. Uh,
I was on the downtown six and this
fucking white dude junky gets on.
I don't know what this guy was,
but he was in the beginnings of being
a junkie because his clothes were still
nice,
but he was clearly fucked up and he was
dropping the n word singing this song.
It was hammered out of his whatever.
He's high out of his mind and he
gets on the subway and he was,
he was singing this song on
going, I'm a crazy end word.
Yes I am. I'm a crazy Edward doing
the best they can. And then we'd go,
he would punch the side of the
train right inside the train.
So all the white people,
immediately we're looking at all the
black people going like, oh, here comes,
here comes the beat down.
How can I position myself so
they know I'm not with him,
that I don't condone that,
any of that shit.
And he just kept fucking doing it and I
saw on their faces the look of what the
fuck did he just say and then
going like, oh, that guy's crazy.
And then,
then the,
then the social awkwardness of them
knowing that we're thinking, wait,
I thought that was an automatic
fucking beat down. That's when I,
that's when I first learned about crazy
wasn't when I first moved to New York.
So what was the game? The game
that you saw? Shut your shit.
It's called shut your God damn mouth
and that's you just, I, for some reason,
I woke up this morning, I woke up this
morning and I just was fucking, I just,
the first thing I thought of and I just
started laughing my ass off and Nia came
out of the bathroom and she saw the bed
shaking like I was under the covers,
just laughing, laying on my side, despite
that was jerking off or something.
She was like, what are you doing? And I
just started, I was like crying, laughing,
going, I got a great idea for a game.
It's called shut your God damn mouth.
She just starts laughing going,
I would love to watch that.
Oh yeah. Either that or hey, just people
like talking, just walking into a high,
as loud as you can quiet.
Do you know,
I had to whisper like
a psycho back in a day.
I had a game I did call reactions and it
was just real, everything was coming up.
But you would just go to the counter at
a supermarket and you would just say the
fucking craziest thing with
a dead straight phase. It
just see how people react.
And you know what's funny like that right
now, we're actually pitching a TV show.
I mean, it's sort of like
jackass meets, uh, the beginning
of a what? What's, what's,
what's that? What's that? What's
that movie where they fought?
Patrice says it was
white people's Scarface.
What's the one with the soap fight club.
Oh, a fight club. Fight Club. Yeah.
Was hilarious. Patrice, you
sit on Opie and Anthony that,
that was white people Scarface,
because he's watched it a zillion times
and cannot understand the connection.
Uh, and I'm not one of those white
people that connects to that movie.
I watched it. I saw it one
time. I watched it. I liked it.
I thought it was a little,
I thought it was okay.
But everybody that like love just doesn't,
meat loaf take his shirt off at some
point in the movie and he looks like I can
never see that again. Was that to
balance out how shredded Brad Pitt was?
You know what I mean?
That movie was fucking weird and I
didn't understand when the guy die,
when he put the gun in his mouth
at the end and shot himself.
It was supposed to kill
the one personality,
but he put a gun in his mouth and
pulled the trigger. It was crazy. Right.
I don't even remember that part.
I just meant when he,
when he beat up the one kid saying
I wanted to, I wanted to uh, rex,
beautiful like that.
They just made me,
that was like that same thing going on
for somebody at ACL for no fucking reason.
And then sat in the stand by that
movie. Nah, Nah man, I didn't. Anyways,
our cartoons, dear
bill, this is, it's, oh,
we didn't ask the fucking guys question
here. We were talking about ABMS.
She said,
what's the breakdown of Douchey sunglasses
verse acceptable versus acceptable
ones? What kind of sunglasses do you wear
and dyspnea have any say in the matter?
I imagine you were very nonthreatening,
low profile.
I can't tell if that's an insult or if
he's calm. Sounds like an insult, right?
Um, no, I don't think it's an insult.
I think this guy is genuinely wants to
know what you could wear to make his girl
stop trashing them. Well, this is
what you have to do. First of all,
depending on where you are
and your relationship is,
is if you feel secure
in your relationship,
maybe she's just doing you a solid and
telling you that you look like a Douche,
but if she's always telling
you everything what to do,
then you have to continue wearing those
glasses and you have to wear them over
to her mother's house,
defiance and wear them into the house
and don't take them off when a mom's
talking to you, that's like a buddy, a
buddy of mine, right? Do Women know women?
Just, I just want me to say
something real quick. Oh God.
More women trashing has what people
are going to be nice to like.
Could you like a guy who's really thinking
about it? And this happens all time.
This guy's got a genuine concern here.
But like for like,
I've heard of guys going,
yeah,
my girl just looked over at me and
looked at that shirt and goes, oh,
it's such a turn off. Take it off and I
want it. It's in my mind I'm just like,
I want to be like, dude, shut the, yeah.
But those guys, those guys deserve it.
They fucking deserve it. Paul, if you,
if you let the woman in your
life talk to you like that,
they fucking deserve it the same
way a woman deserves it. If,
if that guy is a fucking as a minus,
then beating the shit out of you.
But I got us. Yeah, minus and beaten
the shit out of you. But like,
and if they beat you up and that's
just complete bullshit. Could,
if they're walking around being a
fucking asshole, disrespecting you,
that that's on you. Okay. You guys break
up with them. But if the guy says to shut,
you shut up. You know I'm wearing
the shirts. Shut up. Yeah,
we see a dick now. Right? But then
it's like, oh, I'm like, I don't,
that's a total turnoff that discussed.
We take that off. Just flip it around.
What if you have ever said that
to you girl? Exactly. Disgusting.
Makes you look fat. You come
on, you'd never do that.
Even if you said that disgusts me, that
would be it. Listen, here's my aunt.
They went through the fucking dessert
that night. At the meal. Well,
here's my answer to your, to your,
uh, your listener's question here.
If you like them, dude, and you look in
the mirror and you go, you know something,
I liked it. I liked the glare. I
like, if it's orange tent or whatever,
you'd like it. Fucking wear
it. Paul. You know, some,
that's why you and your
wife was so comfortable to
hang around because how many
times you guys tell each other go, fuck
you. He say, go fuck yourself. Right.
You do that, right? Like,
you know, we'll just be like,
ah, you know, something shut.
Like, yeah, shut up. Right. In a loving
way. Like, uh, yeah, but you have to,
you have to keep them.
You got to keep Mafia the same way.
She has to keep you off or you know,
she didn't keep you in check.
He'd golf fucking nine times a week,
right? Yeah, no, no, absolutely.
There's a fine line. And what's
like, you know, yes, exactly. Dude.
I had a buddy of mine, right? He fucking,
we went fishing right when we
were done fishing. Uh, you know,
we drank a bunch of booze or whatever,
we was smoking cigars and his
wife pulls up and you know,
they told their kid about the
dangers of smoking, right?
So the kid starts fucking crying and blah.
There's all this big
fucking thing and the kid,
the guy was literally in the dog house
and I guess maybe because the kid was
crying,
I kind of saw her point,
but he's one of those fucking guys I
wanted to say to him like, dude, you know,
it really helped your relationship. Next
time you drop your kid off in the car,
take out a big fat fucking Cuban
and just light it up. And again,
what are you doing?
I'm smoking a cigar because I enjoy it
when I come home I'm going to watch a
game and I'm smoking this fucking cigar.
And when she says,
why you say,
because you can go fuck yourself and that,
and I'm telling you it's a little blunt.
You can,
you can round off the edges and I want
to say you could go fuck yourself.
I'm just saying that would help your
relationship. It's like that movie.
Remember the movie there with the
Kevin Spacey when she comes home,
what does that in the driveway? He's
like, that is a 1969 Firebird and he just,
I went out, bought it cause I
wanted it go fuck you. Like,
and you saw the look on her face.
There was a shift for the
better in that relationship.
But doesn't he die in the end?
I think it killed. I don't know.
It was that was that, that was a weird
one. He wanted to fuck that 12 year old,
you know, fuck that movie. Sitting
with rose petals falling all over him.
I'm sort of saying, you know what you wear
that you wear the God damn sunglasses.
You want to surface right Jesus,
we're an hour and we got to blow
through these here. Cartoons. Dear bill,
this isn't so much a request for,
for advice, but an offer of one.
Everyone needs to watch more cartoons.
The old school one for kids, looney toons,
et cetera.
I used to be a nice guy and then I started
watching MTV and thinking I was too
cool for cartoons.
Recently,
I watched my son watch cartoons as I
realized and I realized he's in a great
mood because of it. When I changed the
channel, he got mad. But here's the catch.
So did I.
When I changed the Channel Two news
sports or even a show like breaking bad,
Hey I'm on that show.
He said,
I get mad somethings something
gets my adrenaline going.
Oh you get like all amped up this guy,
let a little let them metal world
peace going on here. I would say metal,
like metal Lark,
Metta.
Is it me or can I watch a little
yellow bird talk like a wise ass?
Oh is it me?
Or can watching a yellow little yellow
bird talk like a wise ass help with blood
pressure situations do it if
it works for you. Absolutely.
I went to the gun range the other day,
right?
Squeezed off a few fucking
runs through it. I came.
So it was such a stress reliever.
Really. It's phenomenal.
I don't think it's inexplicably.
You think that if you were doing something
like that and the violence associated
with it, that you would be like,
uh, well I guess he hit a heavy bag.
You feel better. We do
that. Can we do that? Yeah.
You know what's weird is you have to go
over there with somebody else out here
because somebody went in there say,
hey, going to have a gun. All right,
thanks a lot. And they fucking blew
their brains out. No, he's serious. Yeah,
but how would you stop me? Funny. I
got a loaded gun. Get away from me.
Then I just fucking put it in my head.
I think they just don't
want the responsibility. Uh,
I don't even know if that's true.
Somebody just told me that.
That's one of those classic things
at a bar. Somebody told me. Um,
all right, Paul, you know what a Kegger
rater is? A K? Yes. A Keg rater. Right.
He's a guy. All right.
First things first. Hey,
did you hype any shows you have
coming up? Oh, no, not yet. Yeah.
What do you have coming up before we
get through all this bullshit. Oh, okay.
Are you going to be poor?
You can check me out.
I'm going to be a wise guys
comedy club in Syracuse, New York.
May 10th through the 13th and then I got
a big one at the beautiful new levity
live comedy club in West Nyack, New
York. I'm headline and it's my night.
It's a Thursday night. Tickets are already
selling. It's in my neck of the woods.
So please come out.
And uh,
and is that the one with
the sign incorporated these
to funnel? Uh, no, no, no.
That's going to be the new one coming
out in New York. I just ruined,
now they're doing one at,
I'll definitely announced that one.
But levity live is the new one that
Mozilla the alright. Paul offers.
He has my stamp of approval. All
right, thank you. And also bill burn.
I support this comedian and Twitter at
Paul Versey. Jesus' sacrifice. Okay.
Social Security number. I know he fucking
Horn yourself out here. All right.
Kegger rater first thing first.
I'm over 21 years of age,
so no worries about giving
advice to a minor. Recently,
my wife approached me and that's
why we don't have a kegerator. Huh?
He's got a good one here.
He goes, needless to say,
within minutes of that statement,
we now are the proud owners of a new
keg rater and seeing as how I've been
married for eight years and this is the
first time she's ever given approval for
a purchase prior to me buying it.
I'm pretty excited about this.
How do guys get themselves
in that situation?
Unless she's making all the money and
you've got to go to her for cash, right?
Yeah, that'd be, she seems cool
unless she's got a drinking problem,
but that's awesome. Now you know what,
I didn't even think of that. Anyways,
however,
I really need some advice as to what kind
of beer I should keep it stocked with.
Choosing the right beer
is key to the process.
I'm afraid if I buy something like
Amstel light, all my friends will know.
My wife wears the pants in the family.
That's hilarious cause he gets the
calorie less calories here. Um,
if I buy us a stronger, thicker, more
manly beer like Newcastle or Guinness,
I may also have to buy a wheelbarrow to
wheel my friends out of the basement on
weekends. And I really don't need
that level of responsibility.
I can't do anything like Miller
lite or course cause like,
cause I might as well hook the
tap up to the faucet. That's true.
That's very true. I said a long
time ago, the court's light,
that's like vitamin water for alcoholics.
Like all my friends. Yeah. Yeah. Just,
you know, I'm on the wagon, I'm
on the wagon. You're like, dude,
you're fucking drink. It
has, of course the light. Um,
I narrowed it down to those
seconds or Labatt blue.
The only thing with Labatt blue would
be if any French Canadians find out I'm
fucked because you know,
those bastards would be knocking
on my door seven days a week. Uh,
what do you think, Paul? If you had to get
a Kegger rater, if you had to get a cat,
it sounds like this guy doesn't
want to go domestic. Uh,
but he also doesn't want to
go really fattening Sam. Yeah.
Sam, maybe a nice parallel. I would go,
uh, I would go, I would just go classic.
It's a keg. It's a fucking
keg. I would go, bud rises.
That's such a weird thing for your wife
to just purchase it. Like to be like,
yeah, you know what I got to like,
that's, that's pretty fucking cool.
That's beyond cool. That's weird. Almost
like Stacie came home with a loud, yeah,
I've got this big wine rack.
I start doing like little keg raters.
Headstands you don't like, you
don't, you have girl pushups.
She does like the girl version.
What fucking keg stand?
What beer would you put in there?
I get,
I'd get Budweiser because
that's like a classic, like,
like who's going to come home? What are
you gonna come home like norm on cheers.
He just can start pouring
yourself a big mug of beer.
You're going to be a tub of shit.
So I figured the only time you really
going to be pouring like that is if you
have guys over for the game.
Budweiser is a nice middle of the road
that everybody's going to like you drink.
But at the game it's not,
it's not one of the Light Beers shitting
out like now that I'm like, you know,
33 years old and stuff. So my
metabolism is obviously slowing down,
but I gotta be honest with you man,
when I drink three beers,
I feel like a fucking fat bloated.
I could feel my tits getting bigger.
You're about ready to enter. You enter
your whiskey and Scotch years. Yeah,
I think so.
Do you get so because beer just gives
me an output and then you get tired.
Whiskey.
If I drink a whiskey on the rocks now,
which is kind of whiskey
Scotch, that's like a, a,
a vaporizer for alcoholics. Like you
know vaporizer, you have like vaporizer.
If you're gonna smoke weed is the
way to do it, I would think cause it,
it filters out everything except
the shit that gets you high.
You take a hit off it, it, there's
no burning sensation. It, it's, oh,
it's like a mist.
And I swear to God,
if you get high with the vaporizer
versus drinking three or four beers,
like just the fatty tissue you're
going to build on your liver.
Like I would think that a vaporizer is,
I mean obviously no research here
because I'm an idiot, but I, I just,
by looking at it, that's arguably
the healthiest way to get fucked up.
You know what I mean? What's the most
healthy to drink was more healthy.
I have no idea. Well, I would say
for not being fat. Look at, if you,
if you get like a juice drink hard stuff
and you drink it on the rocks or he'd
just drink it neat. And uh, what
people get fucked up is, you know,
they drink like Jack and cokes,
you drinking sodas all night and all
those fucking like alcoholic wards.
Like neat. I would just be regular.
Yeah. Neat is a no, no ice.
That's just straight. Okay. And then
rocks is obviously with some ice,
but you don't want to mix
it with anything. Like, you
know, I guess, you know,
twist of lime. The
older you get, you just,
you just want to go right to the fucking,
you get right to the pill.
It's like how old old people fight.
If they're going to fight,
they're not going to sit there and try it.
You know who used to do that bit
like Richard Pryor, somebody,
they're not going to look cool.
Anything else?
You immediately try to blow out
your knee and just end the ship.
They'll kick in the balls.
They don't give a fuck.
That's the way old people drink.
Like I've heard somebody tell was a
bartender said when somebody comes in,
if they order a beer, I think,
okay, this guy could be a problem.
But if somebody just comes in and they
order like a whiskey or whatever and then
it's this sitting there, you
know, and they know how they
want to think. All right,
this guy's a pro he can handle as a
rookie. Yeah, yeah. Ugly. Oh yeah,
he's coming in. Let me get a, you know,
give me get a shot as Damn Buka a couple.
Yeah. You guys want to do
shots went around those guys.
Yeah, that's going to be,
it's like a car bomb.
As soon as you
do the carb on the dumbest thing,
the Irish carbon,
it's cool because it makes
you drop Amaretto into a beer.
Is that it's a isn't it? It's a
Guinness in it's a shot up. No,
not again. It's, it's uh,
maybe there's a bunch of alcohol to the
end of this podcast. Get me Thursday.
Oh yeah, do it. I'm ready to drink.
Yeah, me too. Like, yeah, yeah, no, no,
we're were boozing after this. Um, yeah,
so sorry. I would go with, but okay,
so he says those seconds of Labatt blue.
You know what I would do?
I wouldn't do the SEC. He's just because
the most interesting man in the world.
It's a little overhype. I go Labatt
blue. I think that's cool. I have,
I can't remember what Labatt blue
chase likes Canadian, right? Yeah.
But does it have the extra alcohol now
Rick wants it comes in and once it comes
into triple x has the extra Oco as the
sec, he's got hurt the second my window.
That's another reason to fucking get
into hockey. When you go up to Canada,
when you drink their beer, it has twice
the alcohol content. You know what,
that's fucking tremendous.
Other than the fact that they're peaceful
and neutral where everything but their
sport is fucking by Barrick and
they drink like fucking maniac do.
And they're not peaceful either.
They're not.
That's just Michael Morris version of
what they are because it worked for his
documentary. Did they lost the hockey
game and they burned down the city.
Talk about an unexplainable face. Exactly.
Michael Morris on the head of that.
I got, I got, I got fucking two
words for Canada grow up. All right,
here's another to act your fucking age.
I'll be in Edmonton at
the, all right. Here's one.
Here's another one when the last
ones here, Doh. Jesus. Bill,
I'm a 23 year old guy
from the Netherlands.
I'm a longtime listener and always looked
forward to listening to your podcast.
Uh, I always have a blast
listening to your podcast.
He said listening three times,
but I'm not giving him shit
cause this is a second language.
So this is very impressive to me. Um,
but every time you talk about religion,
I start cringing.
I don't mind a Jesus joke or two,
but this time it felt really personal
and angry. Well, I'm an angry guy, dude.
I could talk about ice cream
and you'd be like, Jesus,
somebody get him another one. Um, I
might be exaggerating since she, uh,
you had a hangover last
week that we come anyways,
last week you gave an illustration
about why beings from another dimension
dimension would be interested in us, which
made me think, uh, which made me think,
well, I'll play along with your
illustration and explain why a powerful,
intelligent being from another dimension
would be interested in us and in you.
He's trying to explain to me why he
thinks God exists. Uh, yeah. First of all,
do you,
are you a believer?
I believe I put that microphone
down and get the fuck out.
How do I believe in some,
I'm not friends with you anymore.
I thought you were intelligent Napkin.
I respect the fact,
believe in something to fuck yourself.
Uh, well, first of all, this, this being,
this being God made our universe,
made our universe also our dimensions.
Either you believe that or not.
Uh, so would make total sense
for him to be interested in us.
They see what he just did there. He said,
well, first of all, God made everything.
Either you believe it or not.
All right. And then he goes.
So that makes total sense for
him to be interested in us.
Like he just proved that he exists.
This is Grand Canyon in between what
the fuck you started saying and then the
logic you just came to anyways,
he says,
the Bible speaks that God made the
earth in a living space in seven days.
The planet itself already
existed or excited.
I can't read what he wrote
here. God simply made it
into, oh, it already existed.
God simply made it into
a living place for us.
Humans when translated to Hebrew seven
days doesn't literally mean a team of 24
hours, but periods that could've
lasted thousands of years. Oh,
so now it totally makes sense that this
invisible being that nobody's seen.
It could have made this,
why don't you say thousands of years?
You know what's crazy about
this too? It's like, um,
what's comedian willy bar center was
telling me that he went to perform for the
troops and he said they had a tent to
bibles, right? For all the different,
and he said it totally put into
perspective what you know, religion,
because he went into the tent and he said,
you couldn't even count
the amount of bibles.
The amount of different
bibles for different soldiers
for different beliefs is
so much. And my older brother made
a good point. My elder brother goes,
what's wrong with people just saying you
don't know. Yeah, why can't you just say,
listen, I believe in something
and I'll take it. It's a fear.
It's the fear of dying. I believe
in higher power. It's a fear.
It's a fear and Diane, and then they
also have to just the fear of dying,
but they also have to there. Then it's
also control. They had to keep you,
they have to in a way.
It's good because if there wasn't
this fear of our eternal damnation,
you know, just, you know, rape, pillage
and all kinds of shit could be going down.
Like you have to keep human beings
like under control so you don't weave.
So we don't act like a bunch of fucking
savages because we wouldn't act like a
bunch of savages.
You are three days without food and
water away from fucking eat my foot right
now telling you, okay, the only
reason why we're civilized.
You know what it's like?
It's like when you're,
you're the fan of a team that wins a
bunch of championships and you of course,
you're going to go to the stadium, be
classy. Your team's winning. All right?
But all of a sudden
your team starts losing.
That's when you decide whether
he got class or not. You know,
they start litter in the field with shit.
But what do you believe in Belk?
You believe in God? Well, let me finish.
What's, what's going on here? Um, I,
I believe in,
I don't know what the fuck happens in.
Everybody finds out what
happens when you die.
So don't fucking be telling me
definitively what's going, what,
what happens when you die?
If you do that,
you automatically lose points with
me because you don't, because it's,
it's written down by guys and me come
with enough already and stop getting mad
at people because their
version of it isn't like that.
People make the mistake that I'm mad at
people because they believe this stuff.
I don't,
what I don't like is that they fucking
the all the murderer and all this shit
that, that comes out of it and
it's this whole like, uh, like, uh,
everybody like Jewish people with the
whole, with the chosen ones, right?
It's like, why? Why would you
have that fucking written in?
Don't they have that in there?
I don't even know. Like every,
every fucking group or like baptist,
you know,
you're going to go to hell because you
don't fucking spend 20 hours in. True,
I'm getting in trouble.
Like every fucking group here,
Catholics think they're the chosen one.
Every fucking group says, you know,
God loves everybody created all of us,
but he loves us the best.
It's like you're trying to be the
favorite son. It's fucking childish.
And it's that thought right
there too. Yeah, it's that,
yeah, that he gives a fuck.
Yeah. Look, if there's a higher power,
why would he make sociopath just
to keep an interesting, you know,
just to do it. That's, that's,
that's like the wildcat offense when
you just throw the fucking show that
sociopath in there. So
anyways, he goes, yes, Bill.
It's true that you didn't ask Jesus to
die for your sin, but just like God,
he was interested in the human race and
wanted to save them from death and sin.
And yes,
that includes you also.
I understand you have a beef with religion
since those responsible seem to guide
people with God's words and
become greedy and perverted pigs.
And in no way should they carry God's
name, make fun of them all you want,
but please leave Jesus
himself out of this.
All he wanted to do was
help the human race.
I actually think he's right
about that. What did Jesus do? I,
it was just some hippie walking
around, hey man, like, you know,
can't we all get along?
It's right.
So I'll just attack religions
from here on out. Yeah.
I don't really know much about the Bible.
Did I read the sports page?
I can't get through it. He said it
on the you and I can't even read it.
You know what's a good one? No, it's
Solomon. Just those, those quotes to,
I was like, John wouldn't have, then he
just, he just says, you know, wisdom,
this is good shit. I refused.
There's nobody mad at me. Okay.
Other than me. Okay. I'm mad
at myself. Nia gets mad at me,
but God doesn't care. Somebody told
me is my son baptized and I said no,
we're going to do a double.
And my daughter's born and they go,
you gotta get your son baptized cause
you know you want him to go to like,
and it just kind of, they assume
that like what, what my beautiful,
intelligent and God would throw him
into a pit of fire. It's like I just,
that is the most fucking and
look and who came up with that,
who came up with the fucking church goes,
if you don't get this kid fucking
Zombie fied in with what we do doing,
then they're going to take this beautiful
boy and throw him into a learning pit
of hell forever.
I just looked at my son gone and I want
get some Swedish fish and this kid,
this fung, a beautiful little boy, is it
because he didn't get baptized? It's like,
it's such and then they want money,
dude.
And then these priests live
in these houses. Listen,
I don't want to sit here and trash.
Listen and I, and I'll say this now,
I believe in something.
I believe in a higher power and I believe
in a god and I believe it. You know,
I believe that there's something cannot
explain that this is what it is and your
wrong and crazy. I find
arrogant, I find ridiculous.
And to to even insinuate the fact that
my son may not go to heaven because we
didn't do anything yet. So because of me
and my wife being or or you'd be like,
that's ridiculous.
I don't need to be more lazy.
I don't need to go and do a house of
worship. They hijacked what's in me.
That's what I don't like. Cause what
if I do something good? I feel good.
If I do something bad,
I feel bad and it's that feeling
of doing the right thing.
That's your connection to some sort of
higher thing and they hijack it and they
flip it all around and they make this
guy mad at me and then his kid did
something for me and got tortured for
fucking days and days and days from and
they just dump all this guilt on me. It's
like, Oh fuck you are you fucking idiot?
You sound like a guy who's trying to
sell me some piece of shit car right now.
I honestly, this is just my opinion
that I feel that like you, you,
you are fucking, you have your week.
If you buy into that is the pimp game.
That's the same thing you get
and you get me in this insecure,
I'm not worthy.
Let me bow down.
Let's make the ceilings as high as
fucking hell and have these giant fucking
doors that a goddamn parade elephants
could go through. Three, three.
Hi did just make me feel all small
and insignificant and then you,
you're going to stand up there as a
fellow human being and sit there and talk
down to me and your little fancy
fucking Elvis robe. Oh, come on. Yeah.
How old am I?
And you know what,
if I'm not saying I'm a good person and
I'm not saying that if it's a bad place
that you go to, I'm not even
saying that I'm not going there,
but I can tell you right now,
all my friends are going to,
and I want to hang out with
them so I don't give a fuck.
I actually all my buddies dying recently
like made me less afraid of dying
because I know I'm going where
they're going. So I don't want to not,
what am I not going to see
them forever? Cause they, they,
they went to one less titty bar. I went
to one less titty bar than they did.
Right. And then I'm going to hang out
with fucking Jesus going, you know,
I did all that stuff for, you know,
why the fuck would I want to be there?
Hey Buddy, go fuck yourself.
He says, all right,
I'm just fucking around. Surf
from the Netherlands. All right.
You can love Jesus all you want.
I don't have a problem with
them because just like you,
I never met him and don't
send me one next week. Well,
maybe that's what you need to do.
You need to meet them.
You need to bring him into your life.
Not Dude, it's cultish, cultish, cultish.
To what? A fucking way to end this. Let's,
let's end it on something positive. Paul,
go to amazon.com uh, I have
Jesus. Paul, you're the worst.
The hype guy ever. Yeah, no, absolutely
I do. Yeah, of course. I said I have,
let's start over again. Okay. Okay. Take
two. Paul Versey. Paul Versey. Actually,
he's interested in this
advertising. Take two. Hey Paul,
do you have to go to amazon.com always.
It's great, right? It's unbelievable.
Best website on the, on the, on the, on
the Internet, right? Only place I shop.
All right,
well here's something.
Next time you go to amazon.com if
you'd like to donate to my podcast,
just make a little detour.
Go to billboard.com you
click on the podcast on the
right hand side of the plate
page. I got a little loud window.
Is that what you call it? A little,
a little a link. You Click on it,
a banner, amazon.com you go there.
You don't have to do anything else
after that. And if you buy anything,
not saying you have to,
you buy anything. Uh, uh,
I get a kickback from whatever you buy,
donates to the podcast and then 10% of
that I give to the wounded warriors.
So you support me and you support the
troops all at once. And what do you do?
You bought yourself a Flowbee at the
same time. All speed. It can't be,
you can't beat it. Paul Versey that
supports this message. You know what?
That's the podcast for this week.
I'm going to be at the University of
conquered in Concord, New Hampshire.
There's limited tickets left. It is open
to the public. Bring your ass down there.
Uh, I'm building my new hour. Um,
I don't believe I did my old hour in
New Hampshire now. I didn't, I didn't.
So it's gonna be all new stuff.
So get your ass out there and go see some
live performances and Paul Versey once
again. Where are you going to
be in May? I will be at, uh,
wiseguys comedy club in Syracuse
may tend to 13. And the big one,
levity live May 17th in west Nyack,
New York. They go, there you go, guys.
Go out and see some live comedy that it
go fuck yourselves. Don't take any shit.
I'll talk to you next week.